forest johnson won an 80-seat majority
two and a half years ago he is the most
successful conservative prime minister
since
uh margaret thatcher in 1979. and now
there's a confidence phone in him i mean
it actually beggars belief doesn't it i
mean what on earth has happened
well i'm conscious that other people
have decided they think a different
leader would be the best way forward i
don't agree with them i'm supporting the
prime minister i mean i do work with him
on a
on a regular basis particularly focus of
course on my uh departmental objectives
uh in order to get more people back into
work as the primary one um but also you
know differing uh in my constituency as
well and i trust the prime minister and
are you surprised
i don't think it's a case of being
surprised
the prime minister did not get the full
co
every single vote when he stood for
leadership last time and uh but
nevertheless
nevertheless exactly the 86 majority
center if your mps
and we need to deliver our manifesto
choice coffee finally when you went back
to your constituency this weekend how
were your constituents about the prime
minister
actually most people who spoke to me
said you need to keep boris in post did
they yeah most people who spoke to me
i'm not saying everybody spoke to me
there may be people who might want to
say something different but the people
who came and spoke to me i had one
person uh in my entire time in the
jubilee weekend but nevertheless jubilee
weekend was not a time for politics it
was a time of great celebration but back
into politics today i'm hoping we get
through this vote tonight and we can get
on and he's a he's invested he's a dead
man walking thank you very much
dead man he's a strong leader he will
get the get the big calls right and
thank you very much for all your time